violent delusions organ harvesting a
superhero dying in her father's arms
just because a show is animated doesn't
mean writers are afraid to occasionally
inject some disturbing moments into the
mix let's take a look at how animated
shows can get pretty dark sometimes
few animated shows match the widespread
appeal and success of spongebob
squarepants since its debut in 1999 the
show has become nickelodeon's flagship
franchise
spawning ample merchandise and even a
few feature films the inaugural season
takes an unexpectedly dark turn in the
episode
sb129 as is par for the course the
episode begins with squidward tentacles
attempting to escape the constant
annoyance of spongebob and patrick
squidward's efforts lead him into krusty
krab's walk-in freezer where squidward
is frozen for 2000 years eventually
squidward emerges in an all-chrome
future where spongebob's cybertronic
successors give him access to a time
machine
after a wild bout of time travel
involving a prehistoric spongebob and
patrick squidward accidentally breaks
the machine leading to a malfunction
that seemingly strands him in a white
void at first the notion of prolonged
isolation appeals to squidward but he
soon begins to panic after a period of
searching plus a tearful admission that
he misses spongebob he regains control
of the time machine and returns home
it's a classic episode aided by a
variety of unique settings topped off
with a disturbing yet hilarious
depiction of a metaphor for purgatory
what's more it provided fans with one of
the most well-quoted lines in spongebob
history
[Music]
if ever there was a cartoon that lives
and dies by its own macabre
individuality that would most definitely
be invader zim the notion of hyper
violent indie comic creator jonah
vazquez creating a kid's cartoon seems
like a weird enough idea when the show
premiered in 2001. suffice it to say the
show's nightmarish maul goth aesthetic
was definitely a bit much for
nickelodeon's typical demographic
too ugly
too stinky
that one looks good
one episode that gained the series some
notoriety when it aired is dark harvest
which is full of childhood trauma fuel
the time comes for physical checkups at
school while zim has managed to appear
human on a purely surface level this is
not the case for his extraterrestrial
innards in a grotesque attempt to pass
for earthling on the inside he harvests
the organs of other students and stuffs
them within himself
zin becomes a sickening sack of pilfered
organs bursting to the point where
intestines roll out of his mouth it's
this absurd level of cronenberg style
body horror that makes invader zim such
a distinct and memorable series
over the course of its 10 season run
adventure time covers a ton of ground in
terms of tone and visuals the expansive
land of ooo isn't afraid to get dark
case in point the season 3 episode no
one can hear you demonstrates the show's
ability to terrify its audience when it
wants to during an incident with a
rather invasive stag protagonist finn
and jake are both injured after
awakening in the hospital with two
broken legs finn surveys the candy
kingdom only to find it eerily abandoned
he then discovers jake digging through
trash inexplicably convinced that
everyone is hiding to surprise him for
his birthday
after realizing jake has gone crazy finn
also begins to understand that he's been
in a coma for six months finn ventures
into the sewer to discover princess
bubblegum and the rest of the candy
kingdom population stuck to the walls
with melted sugar this is all revealed
to be the work of the stag who removes
his hooves to expose a set of creepy
fingers
the whole episode plays like a colorful
28 days later and is superbly
uncomfortable
for as sugary sweet as the powerpuff
girls looks the show doesn't always
steer clear of brutal violence and body
horror influenced by some darker comic
book creatures creator craig mccracken
and his team use these creepier elements
to help give the show its unique
identity as a result the powerpuff girls
managed to resonate with both boys and
girls during its original run in the mid
90s and early 2000s the season 2 episode
twisted sister marks a particularly
memorable instance of the generally
bright and sunny series taking a hard
turn towards the horrific the girls
burnt out from crime fighting and chores
sneak into the professor's lab to create
a new powerpuff girl to pick up the
slack however due to their scientific
inexperience what emerges from the
concoction is a gigantic and slightly
misshapen powerpuff girl the girls end
up calling their new sister bunny and
show her how to fight crime in
townsville unfortunately bunny is bad at
following instructions and begins
freeing criminals from jail but he
eventually fixes her mistakes but just
as she saves the day her unstable
genetic composition begins to break down
bunny explodes in a blast of white light
with a pile of the ingredients remaining
much to the girl's despair
any compilation of creepy cartoons worth
its salt should include a reference to
courage the cowardly dog from alien
chickens to freaky barbers the turn of
the millennium cartoon network classic
is a buffet of mind-bending animated
terror ironically one of the most
disturbing sequences of the show might
just be one of the most relatable in the
season 4 episode perfect courage's human
antagonist eustis grills the show's
eponymous canine for his inability to
handle certain household tasks these
comments impact courage so much that he
imagines a strict elderly school teacher
who attempts to make him perfect what
follows consists of a series of
increasingly bizarre and disturbing
anxiety-induced nightmares the images
include a stop-motion version of courage
juggling plates and a deranged blue cg
creature who insults courage
[Music]
eventually a bathtub dwelling barracuda
gives courage a pep talk explaining that
there is no such thing as perfect
following this revelation courage is
able to move past his anxieties and
embrace his imperfections for any
viewers who have suffered from anxiety
or depression this episode might hit a
little close to home
avatar the last airbender is the perfect
hybrid of mature writing impeccable
humor and utterly gorgeous animation
throughout its run avatar confronted
more and more serious topics
a major example of the show's increasing
intensity arrives in the season 3
standout the puppet master
while on their journey through the fire
nation team avatar encounters an old
woman named hama who owns an inn in a
nearby village
hama voiced by american animation icon
tress mcneal soon reveals herself to be
a waterbender from the southern water
tribe having never met another
waterbender from her home tribe katara
forms a fast friendship with hama the
two also bond over their shared trauma
much like how katara lost her mother in
a fire nation raid hama was kidnapped by
firebenders and taken from her home
however things turned sinister with a
group look into a series of
disappearances in the village all
carried out at night their search
coincides with hama revealing she
escaped her capture by inventing blood
bending a twisted form of water bending
which allows the user to manipulate the
human body
soon enough hama has aang and saka at
her mercy forcing katara to reluctantly
use blood-binding herself to stop hama
the villain is defeated and carted off
but can only smile knowing she has
passed on her disturbing legacy to an
unwilling student
as the follow-up to avatar the last
airbender the legend of korra had some
big shoes to fill from its inception
not only is avatar a critical darling
its epic multi-part finale wrapped up
the story perfectly when it aired in
2008 set 70 years after the original
show 2012's the legend of korra follows
avatar ing's hot-headed successor as she
journeys into adulthood in season 1 cora
contends with amman the sinister leader
of the anti-bending equalist movement
she must also survive the machinations
of republic city councilman tarlock who
is eventually outed as a blood bender
additionally we discover that amman
whose real name is noahtalk is tarlock's
brother and shares his ability to
bloodbend once amman is defeated at the
hands of korah the two brothers appear
to escape in a speedboat unfortunately
for noah talk tarlock opts to use an
equalist weapon to ignite the boat's
engine and cause a fiery explosion this
unprecedented level of violence sets a
clear tone for the dark series of events
to come in the following seasons
gravity falls is a show that dabbles in
various sub-genres of fantasy science
fiction and horror pre-teen heroes
dipper mabel and their grunkle stan run
into the likes of love gods menacing
poltergeists and all kinds of other
frightening entities however the episode
we're interested in focuses on soos the
mystery shack's lovable handyman in
2014's soos and the real girl the
well-meaning doofus hits a wall in his
search for a legitimate girlfriend his
luck appears to change when he finds a
japanese dating simulator in a bargain
bin and hits it off with the game's
female sim giffany soon enough giffany a
sentient artificial intelligence becomes
obsessed with zeus and aims to make him
hers forever this results in a sequence
reminiscent of five nights at freddy's
in which giffany possesses a legion of
play place mascots it's a delightfully
disturbing episode that shows the
pitfalls of getting caught up in a
fantasy world
anyone who's seen much ed ed and eddie
might guess that creator danny antonucci
has a great appreciation for the horror
genre his affinity for monster movies
becomes obvious through the character of
ed who is obsessed with science fiction
and old splatterflix ed's fixation takes
center stage in the season 3 episode the
day the ed stood still the ed's plan to
scam the other cul-de-sac neighborhood
kids with a fake carnival but their plan
falls apart when ed begins acting up
i am just a monster in a boy's body
eddie attempts to capitalize on ed's
apparent desire to be a monster by
crafting him a costume unfortunately ed
immediately goes berserk and begins to
rampage across the cul-de-sac much to
everyone's horror much like many other
ed ed and eddie episodes this outing is
a solid pile of visual gags however the
day the ed stood still also boasts some
legitimate terror when monster ed begins
sticking the other kids to walls in a
fashion very similar to the deleted
cocoon sequence from the original alien
batman the animated series is regarded
as one of the best interpretations of
the caped crusader ever put on screen
the show is a gem defined by its angular
design style gorgeous noir imagery and
incomparable voice acting i ask you
harley who's given more hours of
amusement to the gotham police force
than me
it also gets unapologetically dark on a
much more routine basis than the other
programs listed here ending plenty of
episodes with deaths or somber moments
however the 1998 episode over the edge
takes the show's usual darkness to a
whole new level after scarecrow lures
batgirl into a trap he pushes her off
the roof of gotham city hall batgirl
crashes onto a police car which just so
happens to be driven by her father
commissioner jim gordon moments before
her death she reveals her identity dad
barbara
while this moment is later revealed to
be part of a fear fear-gas-induced dream
barbara experiences
it doesn't lessen the impact this moment
serves as a great example of just how
mature the minds behind batman the
animated series were willing to get
the mid-2000s teen titans series can
certainly crank up the darkness every so
often a prime example of this is season
three's haunted one of the most intense
episodes of the series in haunted robin
is still struggling to accept that slade
is really dead following the events of
season two's fiery finale
following a late night look at his foe's
dusty remnants robin and the team are
called into action
things take a turn when slade begins
appearing to robin while the other teen
titans can't see him
bit by bit robin begins to lose his
marbles and lash out on his team making
them question their leader's sanity
visions of slade continue to torment
robin causing him both mental anguish
and physical harm
the true highlight of the episode is
scott minville's voice work which
conveys robin's paranoia in increasing
exhaustion immersively robin are you
sure you really saw slade saw him i
fought him you think i did this to
myself for his part ron perlman cranks
up his sinister delivery as slade
serving as the spectre who taunts robin
from the darkness
the sight of the usually chipper boy
wonders slowly losing his mind is
genuinely disturbing
dating all the way back to 1940 tom and
jerry stands as one of the best examples
of how to convey brutally painful
slapstick in animation if an animated
show entails two characters constantly
walloping each other with heavy objects
chances are it's influenced by this
iconic cat mouse duo
however even this classic cartoon can go
too far every now and again and a 1956
episode in which they apparently attempt
suicide lives in infamy
blue cat blues opens with a depressed
tom sitting on the tracks waiting for
the train jerry serving as the narrator
flashes us back to what preceded this
situation in the flashback tom
encounters an attractive female cat
immediately smitten he dedicates every
aspect of his life to pleasing her even
though she is clearly manipulating him
she predictably leaves tom when a richer
cat comes around breaking his heart
jerry laments tom's situation and
expresses gratitude for his stable
relationship with his girlfriend who
promptly rides off with another mouse
this leads jerry now equally broken to
approach tom and ask him to make some
room on the rails
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
dark moments in tv are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]